معنى الان مازن عباس مراسل كانت في موسكو
اهلا بيكا مازن همم اذا هذا القرار الان
اعطي الضوء الاخضر من قبل برلين لارسال
هذه الدبابات الثقيله اليوبارد الى
اوكرانيا ماء جديد
التصريحات الرسميه الروسيه
العسكريه وخاصه الدبابات سينقل الصراع الى
مستوى جديد وان الوضع اصبح يزداد خطوره بل
انا نائب رئيس مجلس القومي
هذه التطورات يمكن ان تؤدي الاندلاع حرب
عالميه ثالثه همم سقوف اليوم اعتبر همم
هذا الامر لا شك انه ضربه قاضيه للعلاقات
الروسيه الالمانيه يعني المستوى السياسي
يا عم من قبل موسكو ومس قطعت اعتبر
اوكرانيا بالاسلحه الحديثه هذه الدبابات
ان الله عمليا يارب
المفاوضات السلميه
وتصعيد للمعارك والعمليات العسكريه الامر
الذي ترى في موسكو انه خلقه لذلك تتدخل
على المسؤوليات تاريخيه للحفاظ على امن
القاهره هل
هذا القرار ربما كان متوقعا من قبل
المانيا وايضا من قبل الولايات المتحده
همم هل كانت تتوقع موسكو بتالي هذه
الخطوات
وهل حضرت سيناريوات اخرى
لتلائم الوضع على الارض
باعتبار ان هناك دعم كبير من الغرب ليه
اوكرانيا وانا على مدار الشهور الماضيه
موسكو طلبه الغرب وقدمت مذكرات يبقى دول
الحلفنيته باقامه وزاره العسكريه ولكنها
لم تلقى استجابه وبالتالي هي كانت الى احد
كبير مستعد للتعامل مع هذا القرار همم
تحدث العديد من الخبراء العسكريين حول همم
افاق او تاثير لان ده الاوكرانيا الدبابات
الالمانيه الامريكيه ايضا همم واشهره الى
ان هذه الخطه الروسيه للمرحله القادمه
الاسابيع القادمه
اعتبار امكانيه تحديث السلاح الاوكراني
ولذلك هناك تكثيف في عمليات القصر
والضربات الجويه واعدوا للاذهان تصريحات
الكريمه التي اشارت الى ان اي شحنه اسلحه
غربيه ستروس وتكون هدفا للقصف الجوي
والمدفع الروسي وبالتالي هناك همم
الخبراء هناك همم ااا اخوكي نت هذه همم
القرارات بالاثبات بل ان هناك تحذير من
الخبراء الروس بان هذه الدبابات تحديدا
الدبابات الالمانيه لان تهدي همم شكل فقد
تهديد العسكري لو انما هي تهديد للبيئه
باعتبار ان قذائف الخارقه للدروع في
الدبابات بها يورانيوم منظم يمكن غبار
اليورانيوم ان يتسبب في انتشار امراض بينه
بساط السكان وايضا يؤثر على الاراضي
الزراعيه شكرا جزيلا لك مازن عباس مراسله
على كل هذه التوضي شكرا لك